the fifth installment of the Pirates of
the Caribbean series is just as
ridiculously fun as any of the prior
four chapters it's just as chock-full of
Easter eggs - here are some subtle and
sometimes not so subtle in jokes from
Pirates of the Caribbean
dead men tell no tales that all ye
landlubbers will just love hi but beware
the spoilers what's in the name
we didn't need Javier Bardem is Captain
Salazar to actually say the line before
the opening credits to get where the
title phrase came from previously it was
spoken in the third film at World's End
even if it was only said during a
voiceover moment at a transition scene
even earlier than that the phrase
appeared in the original Pirates theme
park ride and remember this scene from
curse of the Black Pearl
meanwhile anyone who's been hungry for
some old-school Johnny Depp swagger
should be pleased with this film's
extended glimpse of the swashbuckler in
his younger days thanks to Captain
Salazar we learn exactly where when and
how the captain got his name he defeated
Salazar squad by having them steer into
The Devil's Triangle to be obliterated
and upon first taking command of his
ship in the compass he looked like a
sparrow
we also learned where he got all his odd
accessories after killing Salazar who'd
been on a mission to destroy every
pirate ship in the sea before being
beaten by Sparrow his new crew offered
him his signature beads and hat among
other items of booty as tribute for its
conquest and thus the famed fashion
sense was born the Kraken does speak
Henry Turner is the son of Will Turner
so he definitely heard tale of the
Kraken that his father escaped in
Pirates of the Caribbean Dead Man's
Chest
so when scientists slash skeptic Corinna
Smith makes an offhanded comment about
his probable belief in mermaids in the
Kraken he says the Kraken doesn't speak
and he would know I'm a woman of science
I cannot believe in part do not say
what's behind us interestingly enough as
it was described to Will Turner the
Kraken has the reeking odour of a
thousand rotting corpses and the attack
mode of Captain Salazar ship is quite
reminiscent of the way the Kraken would
down a vessel - and guess what it
definitely smelled like rotting corpses
because it was staffed by undead sailors
rock star pirates it's no secret that
Johnny Depp has a thing for working with
rock stars in fact he considers himself
to be one so after borrowing some of
Keith Richards style to inform Jack
Sparrow's appearance in the Pirates of
the Caribbean franchise he helped the
Rolling Stones guitarist snag an acting
role in at World's End and on Stranger
Tides as his father Captain Teague
unless people keep sayin it must be true
when Richards was unavailable to return
to the fifth film for another cameo
depth turned to another iconic musician
in long time pal Paul McCartney Depp
revealed that the filmmakers needed a
pirate rocker to sub in as his Uncle
Jack and Depp thought of the Beatles
legend first thing inviting him to
appear in the pic via text
you just know they're behind the scene
jam sessions were lit Johnny Depp's
least favorite joke captain sparrows
Uncle Jack offers him a joke as he's
about to be executed for his crimes
against the island a skeleton walks into
a bar orders a mop and a beer double it
up right well Johnny Depp might not have
gotten a writing credit for dead men
tell no tales but he certainly deserved
one because that was equip he'd had a
long history with while he was filming
done in Brasco Alba Chino would tell him
the joke repeatedly and he never quite
understood it he told the Express in
2010 he thought it was my problem he
inflicted it upon me and I could feel my
IQ points drop I finally figured it out
obviously he's come to appreciate the
humor I will hire the stupid nodding to
the timeline when Captain Jack is in
route to his execution he's given the
choice between dying by hanging or dying
by a newfangled guillotine device you
listening that's French I love the
French did you know that I invented my
own eyes while most inspired films have
only loosely honored historical events
and definitely fudged
timeline a bit this reference seems like
a pointed effort to pin down a more
precise date the modern guillotine
wasn't invented until 1789 and was first
used in 1792 around the time of the
French Revolution although we've never
seen it go quite like this
oh and that very random mention of mail
may have had some slight historical
significance well legend has it that
mayonnaise was first formulated as part
of a victory for the Duke de Richelieu
after he beat back the British at Port
Mahone that year Captain Jack might not
be known for his historical humor and
some historians believe it was the
Spanish who actually came up with the
connivance but the fact that he praises
Mayo to a man of the British crown
certainly seemed like a smart dig at the
Redcoats thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to